the Joe Rogan experience I have a
different perspective I think they saw I
have a bunch of old sets for me when I
was alone I was on TV I was doing comedy
like five years four years they're
terrible
yeah but the good thing about it is they
exist and it's lets you see like look
this was in the beginning I was talking
terrible but just keep going just keep
working at it keep working on it you get
better you know like I'm not under any
illusion that I didn't used to suck I
try to talk about it as much as possible
I was terrible when I first started if
you're okay with that being out I don't
give a [ __ ] dude I've been digging into
crates I've been digitizing a lot of my
old VHS [ __ ] trying to you know just for
posterity and going through some of my
old [ __ ] TVs they're all terrible
like the Letterman said is probably the
only thing the Letterman and Def Jam
said and oh six those are only two that
still to this day with the I still stand
beside those jokes everything before
that premium bland starsurge last
comment and then Apollo
comic view all of it unlike Barry that
[ __ ] my biggest fear is becoming famous
whatever the [ __ ] that is
and then Beatty just rolling out some
sort of remember when [ __ ] thread you
just use all the black comics that you
saw twenty years ago
no that's who you were that's that's
part of the process yeah like not like
the process I don't care I'm fine with
it the problem is that the gatekeepers
that decide stuff they only want the
newest shiny things so if they see you
disowning that's problem boy that's the
only problem you don't need those [ __ ]
you don't need gatekeepers internet the
Internet has no gatekeepers you have
people that are podcast to get you on
their podcast you do your own podcast
you put out a lot of content
no gatekeeper but the problem with is
that it takes comics discovering it
because the problem is a young comic is
that you inherit the goals of your
predecessors so as a young comic
especially as a road comic every Road
comic is trying to get on TV so they
make you believe TV this is where you
need to be going don't [ __ ] that YouTube
[ __ ] little [ __ ] I tell you right now
you got
to get on goddamn Letterman you get on
Letterman and then you get the show not
on Letterman and is not a knock on
Letterman and it's worth as a credit but
the worth of a late-night credit in 2006
versus 1996 it's not the same currency
now there was a deflation in the
currency so it got me more rooms it got
me more money but there was no Ray
Romano [ __ ] here's your career choose
your career here's your Kevin J like
yeah it doesn't work like that but the
only but you're chasing with somebody
else one and the game is always moving
the school of fish are always so you
have to be ahead of that curve and it's
just didn't listen to the instincts yeah
it's hard to see where it's going though
if the people from your predecessors the
the guys who were successful when you
were coming up where they were
headlining and you were middle and for
them that mean that was the goal the
goal was The Tonight Show the goal was
yet but I don't think is that hard to
see the future not necessarily see the
future but see the trends of where
people what people are paying attention
to I'm quicker to read Fast Company than
I am a variety or Hollywood Reporter
because we're tech goes that's where
people going but people go they want to
laugh so you figure out a way with that
to integrate laughter into whatever the
new tech of the new that like this
tick-tock [ __ ] whatever this is I seen
it but I don't know a better [ __ ]
figure it out really because that's the
next one is it the next one we brought
up to you which maybe it's music it's
musical vine in a way like it's it's
music sketches but it's still funny it's
entertaining so Tom Segura does it like
all the time he's into it she's okay
he's like ironically doing it but yeah
but he doesn't forget yeah he doesn't
finish this Tom Segura is self-aware
that he's a guy that shouldn't be on tic
TOCs so his existence on tic toc is what
makes it funny it makes it do that [ __ ]
but he's ahead he's ahead he's ahead of
that curve
[Applause]